hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm Dave ruin according to the paperwork
I've got Leanne tweeden and Desi doen
here we go okay Ben Affleck you may have
heard of this guy apparently he's some
kind of Hollywood actor people are very
excited that he's going to be the next
Batman uh he has been a big uh
fundraiser politically especially for
the Democrats uh but he did an interview
in Playboy magazine and it sounds like
he's soured on the money in politics
over time became disillusioned mostly
with the pernicious effect of money in
politics I realized it was about raising
56,000 through a couple dinners and
those bundlers who bring in 1 million or
two million those people are dedicated
they and they believe in what they're
doing I believe in why many of them are
doing it what I don't believe in is that
we now have the need to do it and for me
personally it started to feel gross okay
I'm pretty sure we can all get on board
that it's something we talk about here
especially at the young turkey all the
time money in politics and it's a real
problem if you've lost Hollywood with
money is that is this is this well
that's what I'm saying is this a game
changer if you've lost a guy like B
Affleck who has raised a t i mean he's
pretty much one of the most outspoken uh
celebrities they have if you've lost him
is this really a kind of I'm kind of
impressed that he knows the word
pernicious that's kind of cool I mean
was my pronunciation I don't use
pricious in any sentences really I'm
going to have to up my game but um you
know it's
it's interesting that finally somebody
like him that is very vocal speaks out
about it now because it is disgusting
and gross across all spectrums I I think
politics has gotten to that point where
you know people say oh Obama's back on
the plane he's almost out of office and
he's still fundraising but it is kind of
a gross sort of slimy feeling when you
know oh Obama's coming to Hollywood just
to fundraise just to go to a house and
go home with $5 million it's kind of
like you know stop stop making traffic
terrible in West LA people hate it and
he literally did that two weeks ago
Beverly Hills did a private fundraiser
and it's something like 5 you know it's
bad if you want to take a shower after
you have dinner with these people
because you feel so slimy because you
feel slimy what do you make of this kind
of thing because I think there's
something interesting about Ben Affleck
and Matt Damon because you know Matt
Damon's been a big proponent of uh of
public schools but also sends his kid to
private schools so there's something
like as these guys grow up they're
learning the system is seriously broken
and I'm glad that they are I mean it's
been it's taken a while I guess for some
of this to Dawn on some of the Hollywood
folks about how actually wrong it is
that our that our politics is so infused
with money at every stage of the game
you know I think that that would be
wonderful to get money out but in order
to get money out of our system you have
to elect people who will then be able to
vote to get money out and so term limits
ter liit there are differences about
term limits there are some problems that
I have with it you know it tends to uh
perpetuate the party boss system because
people don't get experience and then
they cannot stay in office long enough I
had that conversation I said four four
years for people in C my husband goes
you know let them have eight they need
they need time to do something but then
get them out so he would be one election
so you get one cycle of eight years and
you can't run for a re-election right
because then people do I think a lot of
people get into politics wanting to make
a difference people are engaged and they
are like I can do something for my
community and and they're engaged about
it but then all of a sudden they realize
they get in I think maybe like Obama
might be the same way you get in you
think oh I'm going to do these I'm going
to be present and then you realize it's
the same the Cog and we you know it just
nothing really changes and it's all
about money and it's all about you know
oh well if I want this pass then I have
to do this and this and this and it's
kind of it just it isn't the ideal
situation everybody thinks it's going to
be when they get in and then money is
corrupt it's like froto in the ring
you're like I got to keep the power and
you have term limits or or you know that
doesn't actually get money out I mean
what you need to do is you have to be
able to elect those people who will then
promise and actually follow through on
voting to get these changes made in
system where are those people cuz we
used already exist but they can't rise
above the den of the money you know
there are folks who are running in
congressional districts and in
Schoolboard races all around but because
money is so deeply infused I mean even
with term limits I don't see how that
term limits at least it's a step in the
right direction that people can you
realize that they're not just going to
sit there and you know a year before a
reelection they're just going to Pander
to whoever is going to give them the
most money and then they just keep doing
the same things even though they promise
to do something else don't you guys
Wonder like when they're supposed to be
working you know what I mean like if you
think about it Obama ran for re-election
that whole last year of his first term
was devoted to getting reelected who's
running the show I always wonder that
like you're supposed to have a a job I
think as a politician you're supposed to
have a job but yet half your term ends
up becoming about re-election even now
he's raising money he's not running for
re-election obviously uh but he's still
raising money for the DNC so it just
sort of never in in the aslum are
running but seriously why don't we ever
talk about campaign Finance anymore we
used to have some McCain fold I mean
there was things that we're trying to
change but literally it's not part of
the national discussion at all oh I
think it's just because it's been taken
over so completely I mean when you have
the oligarchy that we have right now and
I you know I don't think anybody will
disagree with me really on that but when
you have that kind of that that that
level of of oligarchy and money in
politics they've really infiltrated at
all levels you know we have the Alec the
American legislative Exchange coun the
template legislation that been put
throughout Republican legislates
throughout the country that have helped
to cement this corporate control and
this this sort of the billionaires uh
influencing pretty much everything that
actually can get done because they have
the money and then you have somebody
like Tom Styer the hedge fund
billionaire who's now decided to step in
because he realizes climate change is an
deeply important issue and so he's
putting his money to work Michael
Bloomberg putting his money to work we
got Bloomberg and we've got Styer we've
got billionaire action on their
billionaire on billionaire action is is
what we're working on and and I don't
know if that's actually going to work if
they're going to be able to get those
people elected and over that hump of
campaign financing to get to the
congressional election so that they can
vote for these politics and politicians
are all about money whether you're
Democrat Republican libertarian nothing
green party whatever it's all money and
they're all the same I mean people talk
about Democrat and Republicans and
really when you look at a on the broad
spectrum sure maybe you're like okay
there's differences between the two
really when you look at it with a
microscope there's really no difference
they're all about money they all are
rich they're all are you know well that
also is proven all the time when you see
who they G who Wall Street gives money
to it's not that they give 80% to
Republicans and 20% to Democrats it's
always around 49 and 51% because they're
playing both sides of course constantly
of course and those people all all have
you know stocks and on on Wall Street I
mean you know so it's not like the the
Democrats over there going oh no we have
no money invested in the stock market we
have no vested interest in wall come on
they all do right well I actually know
some individuals who are just regular
people who decided that they wanted to
try yeah regular people I mean that's
what I mean you know mdle middle class
folks who are not wealthy who are not
folks who are billionaires or even
millionaires or even thousandaires um
who tried to run for Congress and the
barriers to entry are very high part of
that is set by your state legislature
you have to have $10,000 just to file in
some of these states or more and with
those kinds of barriers to entry for a
regular person to then be able to ride
above the den of of the money that is
influencing right there that they have
to to me they're not all the same I mean
I know people I know physical
individuals who have tried to do this
and it's extremely difficult so so maybe
the ones that rise up ultimately become
all the same but at the Grassroots level
there level the people that we would
need to get elected and in place in
order to put the judges in place who say
corporations are not people in order to
get you know the Constitutional
Amendments those all all spin on the
House of Representatives yeah okay so
final thought on this which you just uh
gave me a perfect segue for is how much
of this should we blame on the Supreme
Court and the citizens united ruling
because corporations can now give they
they had back Channel ways to do it but
now we've completely opened it up and so
should we be blaming the Supreme Court
for uh this situation that we're in
now I blame everybody you know what I
mean government obviously there's a we
need government for democracy and to
make the laws and the rules and stuff
like that and it's so there's so many
rules and things that we have to follow
and do that it just you almost wish you
could start over and and just start with
a clean template and say this is what we
need to do and you don't have to do a
million things to do this or you know it
just I don't know I think it's we need
the Supreme Court and rulings like that
you kind of shake your head and go
really now you're going to make it easy
for corporations to do these things that
they were hiding to do before I don't
know I mean bring us home I think the
Supreme Court is the fulm you know it is
the pivot on which everything is is
going to turn and you know they're sort
of the the the last ditch the the wall
the guard rail if you want to use
another metaphor that keeps us from
sliding completely into complete
takeover corations their decision or not
yeah but so so that's that's I think
where the Crux of it lies because these
people you know have a lifetime
appointment so it really does matter
who's in the Senate to approve the
person who is the person in the
presidential office to nominate the
people that we're going to see and we
see the fruits of of you know Scalia and
delo and Thomas uh it just it leaves us
in a place where we are extremely
vulnerable to the kinds of overtaking
the kinds of systems that that overtake
us that make us in a very very diff need
limits
too they do that's that's a whole other
topic that's a whole other topic which
we'll deal with uh maybe next week we'll
see all right let's talk about our
friends over at the NSA they're not just
reading your emails and tracking your
phone calls they're also following what
video games you play which is why I'm
happy that I'm still on Sega Genesis
playing Ghouls and ghosts they are
tracking you on World of Warcraft second
life and a bunch of other online games
uh this is according to the New York
Times the guardian and
prua uh the NSA and its British
counterpart which is the
gcq the UK's government Communications
Headquarters I think that's where uh
James Bond used to work if I'm not
mistaken uh they are spying across uh
Gamers all over the world because it's
sort of a they believe it to be sort of
a secret Zone that uh terrorists can
talk to each other not just guys sitting
in a basement uh getting fatter and
playing games spy agencies are worried
that these games serve as a good cover
for terrorists to use in-game messaging
systems to swap information recruit
other users or carry out virtual weapons
training so that's two things they can
chat with each other in the games and by
playing the games you might learn how to
use uh an actual real weapon and the NSA
was extracting World of War Warcraft
data trying to tie specific accounts and
characters to Islamic extremism and arms
dealing efforts I mean this sounds
completely crazy the gchq had
successfully been able to get the
discussions between different game
players on Xbox Live and so many US
spies were roaming around second life
that a special deconfliction unit was
set up to prevent them from stepping on
each other's toes I mean really think
about that we've got so many people
spying that they they're spying on each
other this is becoming spy vers spy um
is this just like another one of these
things where it's first it was our
emails then our buddy lists then our
phone calls and our FaceTime video chats
and now of course this was just the next
logical step right oh well yes this is
what they've wanted all along this total
information awareness you know and they
want to be able to infiltrate every
single corner of every single Pixel
everywhere throughout the entire world
because that's what they believe is
important also I think they want to play
video games at work but so I really
believe that like I bet you that a good
percentage of these guys are literally
just playing games all day sure why not
wandering around second life just to see
if they can bump into each other and of
course they're only bumping into other
spies and I think what's important about
this is that they still have yet as far
as the paperwork uh shows they still
have yet to prove that there's any
evidence of this activity going on yeah
so okay it goes from one thing to
another I mean I'm guessing you're not
surprised by this I'm not surprised and
I almost wish I didn't know you know
what what I what I don't know is not
going to hurt me if they're watching me
play video games whatever I'm not doing
anything wrong but it is I mean it's
like big brother I know people are going
to jump all over you for saying that if
I'm not doing anything wrong well right
of course but I really don't care if
they're you know listening to my phone
calls or reading my emails I have
nothing to hide but I I understand the
they're you know invading our privacy at
what point is the net to big to protect
us on a larger scale well we're doing
this for the good of everyone we got to
maybe read your emails and fish through
your phone calls because we're trying to
find the terrorists that could be taking
down you know you we could have another
911 right I get it even though there's
no evidence no right of course but but
then if they don't do something then
people are going to be like well you
weren't doing enough right I so I I
don't know well yeah the the the
incentive is obviously you don't none of
us want to find out that this could that
that some h major attack happens and it
could have been prevented if only
somebody had been wandering around
second life you nobody wants that how
crazy yes but yes so so so but you know
there is going to be blame
blame absolutely so we're always dealing
in the what if that happens well we
should have been doing that is the
justification for many things the I
think the other side of it and you know
granted you know none of us were
probably doing anything to be afraid of
in so many words but that's not the
issue the issue is abuse of power right
uh you know the abuse of this
information to uh maliciously prosecute
people or maliciously uh blackmail
people because you know things about
them in this life that they have the
expectation of privacy so we and it was
also broke last week that they were
tracking uh potential terrorist they
were tracking their porn use because
they felt they could then use that as
propaganda because it shows that they're
not honest and they're not really say
that it's for terrorists but do we
actually know that that's what they were
looking at they weren't looking at
congressmen for example they weren't
looking at political opponents right
because you could blackmail literally
any is actually happening in the world
right now I mean with Don seagan former
governor of Alabama in prison now a
political prosecution so you know look
it up you can get more information on it
but he's a direct person that you can
watching porn to me that's only a good
thing because I think distract they're
distracted they're relaxed I think they
probably will have a lot less angst and
maybe want to keep living instead of
blowing themselves up along with all
their other people well that's the thing
but they were saying they were saying
that this is the way if you can find out
what porn they watch then we can
humiliate them and that Hur hurts the
cause that was that was the argument but
how much do the companies that make the
video games Microsoft let's say who
makes Xbox how much responsibility do
they have to actually protect the
virtual world that they're making I
think they're more interested in
protecting their profits and protecting
the kinds of legislation that will help
them maximize their profits I think they
really don't particularly care whether
or not you know Gamers don't trust them
anymore at some point I think if you
don't want to be on the radar do not be
on the radar don't have a cell phone
don't play online don't use the
worldwide web go live in a cabin in
Alaska where you go out and hunt your
own food you don't have cable service
you know what I mean well sure exactly I
was just watching survival or something
on Nat Geo and and there was a guy that
had been living out literally in remote
Forest hadn't seen people you had to be
like hey I'm friendly is it okay if I
come toward your house you know cuz he
lives he chooses to live out in the
middle of nowhere and not be connected
to anything so I'm just saying that you
know as a person that if you're on a
phone it can be monitored if you're on
the internet it can be monitored if
you're on a game box that's connected to
the world you want to play some random
dude in norw you know in Norway then you
know that there's a possibility that
somebody can tap in or that somebody
could be watching or listening and sure
there's a possibility but I don't see
why we have to put up with that so
that's my so that's a final question on
this is what do we do because as I
started this every week so you think the
answer is just to shut it down all
together but I I don't know how
realistic that is we all have this stuff
human progress you can't have a job
without having you can't function in
society without this so what is there
minor steps that we can actually take to
to fight this growing encroachment on
our sure it's what happens uh it's a
pendulum and it happens every couple of
decades here in the United States
Eisenhower warned us about this you know
the military industrial complex well
it's the military intelligence
industrial complex now um you know we're
spending a ton of money on these guys to
play in video games but we don't happen
to have money for food stamps we don't
happen to have money for veterans you
know this is the kind of we
have to deal with I think part of it
starts with electing the right people to
Congress and also making sure that we uh
put in place the kinds of Investigations
and then the kinds of controls that
we've put in place before it's not like
we haven't had this conversation in this
country before it's just had taken a
different tag yeah all right perfect
wrap up for that one and also a perfect
segue because let's talk about tech
addiction note I am not tweeting right
now believe it or not but yeah people
are becoming addicted to all the
technology the Twitter and the Facebook
and I know the kids are on the Snapchat
and all that stuff uh a software firm
front rage surveyed more than 800
smartphone users from all over the world
to see how they felt about technology
usage and addiction 53% of people feel
anxious when they can't use their phone
I think we've all felt that a little bit
there was a 39% increase in frustration
levels when they couldn't check their
emails or social networks and were 79%
more anxious when they couldn't call or
text people 40 5% use their phones at
least once an hour and 66% admitted they
couldn't go a day without their Gadget I
think some of those numbers are low
really yes that's you know that's wild
because they're they're actually pretty
high but I I definitely can see the
argument for that seems low I mean you
you use your phone once an hour I think
I'm looking at it every few even though
I would say yes I'm a little bit
addicted but if I left my phone at home
oh whoops I've left my phone at home and
you just have to deal with it sure
you're thinking oh am I missing a call
am I gosh I should check my emails but
you know one of my girlfriends Brandy
she is constantly on her phone and I'm
like I think you need to put that down
because it's like really all the time
and it's a little annoying you know
you've been at dinners where people go
put them in the bowl and everybody has
to take out their cell phones and the
first person who reaches for their phone
has to pay for dinner yeah so I actually
I was at a uh a party this weekend and I
did that and a couple other people we
all stacked up our phones and we were
present and aware and we had
conversations that made eye contact with
each
other but really how what do we do about
this because we're all suffering from it
I mean I see this all the time you know
back in the day if you were watching a
sports game even something so simple
you'd watch a game and you could watch
with some friends or by yourself and
that's it but now it's like everyone's
even tweeting sports games like every oh
he scored great I saw that to tweet
about is is there's something going on
here I really I'm thinking this stuff is
really starting to affect our brains and
our you know feedback and all that
there's some indication that it is
actually affecting our brains so there's
a lot of cognitive science where they
followed you know how how they do tests
with rats experiments with rats where
they give them a treat and then they
show that the little electrodes in their
brain show that the reward center lights
up and there was another study that I
had read a while ago about people who
check with Facebook and they get the
same lighting up part of their brain uh
the reward center lights up every time
they check Facebook so they they think
that it has to do something that has to
do with our need to have that instant
gratification and the more we get
accustomed to having instant
gratification it becomes like a drug it
has the same influence as something like
cocaine does and it's instant instant
instant I mean I remember I you know and
we're all doing it so it's not shamed
it's not like something that you do
privately think it's something in this
culture that all of a sudden we're we're
now the internet-based instant atyou
fingertips information people it's just
the way it is I mean what there's that
baby seat that has the attachment for
the iPad for babies so even though
babies should not be looking at a screen
for two years of their life and I have a
three-month-old and sometimes I'll pick
up my phone if somebody's calling or
something and I see him looking at the
bright light and I'm like no no no I try
to turn it away from him but I mean
children I I see little kids that can't
even talk yet and they know how to
unlock their mom's phone but what are
you going to do that's technology today
and that is going to be their life and
their world they've never I I remember
going to school and learning how to do
long form had to log into a computer in
like middle school now kids have known
swipe technology since they were born
and that's just going to be their life
yeah and have you seen these videos
where these kids because they're on uh
the iPads all the time they'll even see
like a fish tank something actually real
and they can't and and they're trying to
swipe fish and people or a TV and people
think it's so cute but it's actually
dangerous you think about that you're
like that's scary and it takes awareness
I think you know you ask what do we do
about this I think a lot of that has to
do parenting actual
and awareness you and that's a very
difficult thing you know we to get that
awareness out to parents you know it's
taken this long for us to have PSAs that
tell parents how to feed their children
fruits and vegetables and it's hey
you're the boss of the TV eventually I
think you know as a society we tend to
just roll one head first into the new
technologies without figuring out what
the social aspects of it are so we tend
to find out might take a long time might
take a generation to figure out which is
really unfortunate because we're going
to have a lot of add short attention
span kids coming and then you prescribe
Aderall to all of them I then it becomes
this self-fulfilling prophecy we're an
overmedicated Society so you create a
situation where people want instant
gratification all the time then they
can't pay attention to anything so you
give them a drug for that and then them
a pill with an instant issue with an
instant response rather than actually
like finding ways to adjust our
behaviors yeah it's actually but I think
I find now that you know in the mornings
I used to log on to a website I stopped
watching television news a long time ago
because they're so behind and you'd W
you know you'd look up all your sites
online and now I just go to Twitter
because I follow all the news things and
you follow you see breaking news as it
happens it is addictive because the
first thing I wake up in the morning I
grab my phone and I'm like oh my God
that's happened oh that person just died
oh that's tragic I mean but but but
that's how you're finding it like right
then and now I mean celebrities don't
even need publist anymore because they
just go make their own you know
statement on Twitter or Facebook and
right so there so there's obviously good
in it that kind of thing and you can get
news quickly and we can share it but
that is the addictive quality of it so
have you guys ever had the Phantom Buzz
of course so like or you hear a phone
and you're like is that me and my
husband's like no that my phone like oh
have you had that too where you you know
so I really believe it's doing things
that where you suddenly think your phone
is vibrating and then you realize it's
not even in your pocket I mean these are
things that are actually happening and
we talk we joke about it but it's
actually well I think the interesting
thing if I if I remember from that study
uh that they just did that when people
went without their devices for a little
while they did find that you know after
I think they ing a peak of anxiety they
actually relaxed and they put it down
and they were very proud of themselves
for not picking it up again and I think
that that shows that it can work just
simple Behavior adjustments yeah my my
girlfriend and I joke that sometimes you
know you grab everything when you're
leaving the house you grab your purse
you grab your keys you're like okay do I
have everything and you walk out and
you're like wait a minute where's my
phone and we we we joke that it's our
oxygen because you take two steps and
you go where's my phone I can't breathe
without it and you have to run back in
and grab your phone before you even get
in the car I mean it I realized it as
I'm walking out the door I don't even
get to 5 minutes later and go do I have
my phone no it's like an instant where
is it is this one of these things where
it's like everyone always wants to
hearken back to another time you know
it's sort of like midnight in Paris you
always think something that you didn't
live through was better than what you're
living through but there think about how
fundamentally different if you were to
take the the life of someone growing up
in the in the
1950s versus what's happening now I mean
this this genuinely is going to change
everything about humanity and how we we
operate with each other right I believe
you're right about that well it's
already changed I it's already done I I
remember going to concerts you know you
would go it's like going to the Staple
Center and you're like you you wouldn't
be like hey where are you oh yeah I see
you walking towards okay cool hey great
and then you hang up the phone and
you're already face to face I remember
it's like okay as soon as the concert's
done I'll meet you by the bathroom at
Hall D in in the mezzanine level and
just stay there don't don't move you
know and you would just sit there and
you would wait for somebody because you
beforehand you would talk about where
you were going to meet you didn't have
cell phones you couldn't text you didn't
know where anybody was surv how did we
how' we ever meet anyone for dinner I
have no idea uh just for the record
though I do want to say that I've been
basically taking Sundays off Twitter
good for you Bas basically basically
basically five or 10 or 20 tweets but
that's it are you having any Phantom
buzzing con I'm having it right now
constantly all right let's talk about
another world Mars This Mars one uh
operation I think this is really really
cool so this is a project that's aiming
to send volunteers on a oneway trip to
Mars you will die on Mars if you want to
go it's going to be the first private
unmanned mission to the red planet so
there's two things we're going to send
people one way and they're building a
reality show around that and it's going
to be this giant crowdfunded thing
pretty cool and then they're also
sending unman missions there to do some
other stuff okay so Mars 1 has secured
Lockheed Martin Space Systems and Su
satellite technology for an unman
Mission launching in 2018 which involves
a robotic Lander and a communication s
satellite so basically they're going to
set up some stuff so that when these
people get to Mars there's something
there the unman mission will also carry
the winning projects from an experiment
contest because they're going to be
building this giant reality show uh
around it it's going to be the first
privately funded Planetary Exploration
Mission funding will come from
sponsorships exclusive Partnerships the
reality TV show and Indiegogo we know a
little something about that around here
at tyt uh the trip takes about seven
months the first Pioneers could land on
Mars in about
2025 and after the first humans arrive
in 2025 the plan is to send additional
Crews every two years but again once you
get there you cannot come back this is
what the colony eventually will look
like certainly not the day they get
there now we've got a little bit of the
habitat that looks pretty good right
like very uh 200ish so this whole thing
I think is really cool and you know we
were just talking about all the Social
Media stuff but this seems like
technology that's actually good and
pushing the frontiers of what humans are
capable of doing um would either one of
you like to go on a one-way trip to Mars
Desy absolutely not no you don't want to
do it neither one of you no I wouldn't
do it I wouldn't do it but also I would
want to make sure that you actually
survive the trip and you know there's so
many issues so you be on the second or
third wave you'll let the guinea pigs go
first yeah let the let the guinea pigs
go first because there's so many issues
with this particular uh trip that
they're planning so I'm not exactly sure
whether or not they really will get
there this particular the privately
funded with the reality show is a great
way to make money but I don't know if
they actually will have the capability
to get the technology in place to do it
I mean it's really difficult to land on
Mars you've got radiation issues
Crossing and living on Mars you've got
issues with food with water with
whatever you're going to carry for your
fuel you know there all kinds of there's
tons of stuff there was a there was a
big Mars conference back in May and
there's some great articles that were
written about all of the specific
difficulty of trying to land a payload
with humans on it on Mars and right now
it can't be done I think it'd be great
if they can figure out how to do it
right soing about it so it's great I
mean it's working it's working already
and they got people you know you had to
I think pay 40 or 50 bucks in order to
be one of the people to apply to go on
Mars so that was a great money-making
opportunity right there and literally
hundreds of thousands of people over
200,000 people uh applied for this so
before we get into the specifics of what
they're going to do on Mars what what do
you make of the people that are willing
to do this that someone's going to say I
I will potentially die and root
potentially live there for a year and
die of loneliness or lack of O like what
do you make of the person that can do it
to me my first reaction is to think hm
who is going to go and I think well
they're probably not going to get
scientists or people like that that
would actually be able to study and to
translate what it is that they're seeing
and communicate every day like a crazy
Cal like a space well is it going to be
you know people in prison is it going to
be people that have a terminal illness
is it going to be people that are that
want a death wish I mean so you don't
think there's just a scientist that says
I believe in this so much that I'm
willing to die for right because usually
scientists have dedicated their whole
lives I doubt they're going to dedicate
maybe a few years of their life and then
die off when it just doesn't seem real
to me like you said maybe if people go
and it's successful and people are
living there and then maybe they do find
a way to get them back off and back to
Earth then maybe sure you're going to
have the scientists and and and the
people that go up there that can go oh
okay I can go up there for four months
like space station and and do some
research and we'll we'll come back you
know but a one-way ticket no who's going
to bury you who's going to who's going
to want to be there who's the second
wave guy is going to bury you they're
going to send then they're going to send
a ditch digger on the second wave I
think but have you guys seen the movie
uh contact with jod Foster so you
remember Matthew MCC he says to her
before she goes on the trip he says why
you why you and she says well this could
be the most powerfully impactful moment
in human civilization so I do think
there are some scientists that would be
willing to do it I mean I sort of want
to see what happens with the show you
know let's see what happens with this
say in the article that people who
donate to Indiegogo has some say on what
happens in the reality show so you can
tell the right like like hey you go walk
outside without your mask on what let's
see what happens right they're going to
have punked on Mars um so let's talk
about that so I think one of the things
that's really cool about this is this
isn't just the government uh deciding to
do this this is privately funded and
NASA is going to get involved some ways
and I'm sure yeah they have to be and of
course all the the you know the Russian
space station all that and the
international thing and everything but I
think the idea of privately funding
something and then building a reality
show around it this seems like you know
the world crowdsourcing something which
I think actually is is pretty cool that
model uh you know using this particular
thing as a model for hey how do we uh
undergo major projects that have a
global backing behind them that's a
great idea you know but I can think of
other things that were probably more
plausible it would actually go for
not this planet you know maybe some
actual like difficult problems and
challenges that we have to deal with and
I'm sure there are a couple that we can
think of that money would go well for
I'm glad that they're doing this I think
it excites people about stem you know
science technology engineering math it
excites kids uh I don't know that these
are the right people to do it but at
least they're getting the conversation
going yeah and so for that I'm glad that
they're doing so so joking aside about
what's going to happen to the people
when they get up here you know every
science fiction movie ever from 2011
alien I mean the list goes on and on
about these people exploring the
frontiers of space they always end
poorly they always you know they meet an
alien that kills them or they go crazy
or you know they start seeing things
prometh I mean literally every movie um
so have we already sort of have our
imaginations already predicted how this
whole thing will play obviously if it's
starting with a oneway ticket you know
it is not going to end well so if you're
not that smart to even think down the
line that it could end well then you
have an issue but then maybe you should
go but you know I think it I I do hate
the word reality television show because
I think of Snookie and you know Dancing
with the Stars no this it's almost like
I know can we nominate some people some
people would actually fund that well
let's think if we're doing a one-way
trip who should we send Chris Brown car
Carl Rose give me one more give me one
more the Coke brothers one more come on
snook snooky would be a good one all
right some of those reality people I
think it's more of a documentary than
than a reality show you know when you
when you think of the word do you know
reality I think of you know people
sleeping with each other and running out
on Mars in the middle of the night drunk
and you that would be interesting to
watch though that would be something all
right well there's obviously going to be
plenty plent we get send Bieber too
there's going to be plenty more to talk
about that so we will cover it from now
until uh they get there in 2025 okay
let's move on to McDonald's they had
another major Gaff so McDonald's has
this McDonald's Mick resource line
because they put Mick in front of
everything it's brilliant uh and this is
where they give tips lifestyle tidbits
to assist their employees uh and NBC
News checked out the site last week and
found this article dedicated to tipping
service that their employees should give
to the people that are serving them
during the holidays so this is what
McDonald's wants their employees to be
giving to their employees uh for your op
a gift from your family or or one week's
pay plus a small gift from your child
for your housekeeper one day's pay uh
your pool cleaner because most uh people
making the $7 and change at McDonald's
have a pool uh cost of one cleaning uh
the article also lists holiday tipping
pointers for your dog walker your
massage therapist of course and your
personal fitness trainer uh just a
little bit more about numbers and money
in McDonald's uh CEO James Skinner made
about 14 million last year okay that's
actually not that's actually not crazy
amount in the world of CEOs but it is a
lot obviously uh but that breaks down to
9,247 per hour do you know how long it
would take the average McDonald's worker
who makes
$7.75 to make that a cool four months
yeah four months this guy makes employee
full and a lot of McDonald's workers are
part-time employees that would take
eight months yeah okay so let let's just
start with with that part of it and then
we'll get into the specifics of this uh
of This Ti of thing the money breakdown
and the CEO is making this crazy amount
and we see every year it gets worse and
worse the the disparity between uh the
CEO pay and the average worker pay just
gets worse and worse is there anything
we can do to stop this I guess they're
trying even just this last week we had
these protests sure they're trying to
get at least $15 an hour I me your Big
Mac's going to go up in price a little
bit because they're not certainly they
don't want to take away his money his
salary or shareholder profit exactly
shareholder profit salaries for people
that you know obviously this guy's
making $4 million and and somebody's
trying to survive with their Nanny with
the dog walker their pool and their
fitness trainer while they're not
working in McDonald's obviously it's
insane these people obviously did not
look before you know McDonald's well it
was a third- party person that put this
on our website we just didn't look at it
but who was the third party person
looking thinking that McDonald's workers
had an opair all right so we'll get to
the specifics of this ridiculous thing
in a second but what can we do about
really what can we do about this CEO to
average worker pay well I think it
starts with the federal minimum wage
that's that's like a a beginning place
because we have so many people to lift
out of poverty and to uh help those
people actually participate in the
economy and when they participate in the
economy in the economy they're more
likely to vote and by voting and making
sure that you know people who actually
care about them and actually work for
them and actually share their values get
into office to make sure that when we
have incentives and subsidies that are
being given away to corporations that
Congress votes on that those people
don't let those subsidies go through you
and what would you argue to the crazy
capitalists the purists who would say
well if you do that then the dollar menu
is going to disappear and they're going
to fire everybody and replace them all
with robots what's the argument it's
absolute there is no economic
data that proves that you know if the
economic data shows that when you lift
people out of poverty into the middle
class that it actually helps the economy
because that that money gets circulated
throughout the economy you know wealthy
people CEOs they don't buy stuff what
they do is they maybe will buy some
luxury items but they'll invest the rest
and it doesn't get circulated in the
economy you know when people are at the
middle class or lower you know I think
it's something like the vast majority of
Americans make $60,000 a year or less
that's a lot of folks who will
immediately put that money back into the
economy so when you treat labor as an
expense rather than an asset that is I
think the the the place where capitalism
falters and unfettered capitalism
actually is a detriment to society okay
so now let's talk about this the MC
resource thing itself because obviously
this is completely insane and yes
they're saying it was a third party but
they still put it on their website it
reminded me responsible they're still
responsible it reminded me of the thing
did you see a couple weeks ago Walmart
that Walmart store had a um you
know yeah they wanted people to help
other Walmart employees meanwhile the
two owners uh the sisters that own
Walmart are what the two or three
richest people in America or something
like that I mean really really crazy
stuff so is there just really some
disconnect between uh the corporate
level of these companies like McDonald's
and then what is really happening on the
ground that they could get that this
could even happen well of course I think
there is disconnect but there's also
people I probably don't really give a
about their jobs you know oh here
we're we're making a list of things to
do for how to tip for the holidays and
they just put it on the site without
even it's like they don't even care to
look can go oh you know this probably
doesn't fit with the McDonald's employee
let's adjust it or change it cuz God
forbid that might take some work for
them to maybe make another list than the
one that they already created and using
that template you know okay so I I think
that's very legit that we everyone sees
this and you want to get crazy you see
what McDonald's is doing and but I do
think it's very possible that what
you're saying is right that it's this is
just some mid-level person not doing
their that's not being paid who had to
put this together from you know stuff
that they found on the internet yeah um
so the inequality thing it's is there
anything else we can do forgetting the
the fast food but just the general
inequality thing Obama said food at home
make your own food at home I guess
that's well you know people always say
uh that if you keep that food low it's
that the lower uh poor people need that
food which I'm always not so sure that
that's true because for the $8 that you
spend at McDonald's to get a Big Mac
meal or whatever it is you could go to
Trader Joe's and still get a PR decently
healthy meal for $8 right AG yeah I mean
you know when we look at say our farm
system you know we subsidize food
processors we subsidize Commodities that
actually then make ingredients cheap for
the manufactured food industry and we
don't give any assistance whatsoever to
uh the the Organics or the fruits and
vegetables people you know those those
Farmers don't get that help well you
know it's a problem when you can get a
big Mach meal for $2.99 with a large
Coke with fries that are fried and then
you want a salad that's kind of healthy
that maybe has some fresh you know
vegetables on it with a side of fruit
and it's $10 yeah can see that there's
you with your dollar yeah you know and I
think that you know you you share the
information with everybody in your
network because that's how it works you
tell your friends and family and make
sure that they understand what the
issues actually are that cheap food
comes at a price and it doesn't come at
a price that's good for you of course
they going people that don't care you
know I think a lot of people are
educated and they've seen all the videos
of how they process food stuff and they
still go yeah we'll talk about I can
still get out with a bag of food for $3
I think a lot fewer people are are
actually educated about it than we
realize you know there have been some
recent polls that show a lot of folks
really don't know about these issues
because they're too busy trying to make
ends mean and raise their kids and you
know get a good night's sleep so they
can get up again and do it all tomorrow
and they don't really have all that
information you know and that
information yeah and that's exactly why
we've talked many times here about all
these corn subsidies so then they put
high fructose corn syrup and everything
so that sugar is actually too expensive
for Coke to put in Coke they're you're
drinking corn people corn yeah okay uh
but let's talk about some other things
that you might be drinking uh this is
good if you're an alcoholic in Amsterdam
uh a new program in Amsterdam is
literally paying alcoholics with beer to
clean up trash off the streets uh it's a
privately uh created program but the
government is funding some of it uh in
exchange for cleaning litter off the
streets workers get two beers before
before work at 9:00 a.m. two beers at
lunch two beers after work half a packet
of rolling tobacco so even if you didn't
have a tobacco problem before you will
have one now you do get a free lunch uh
which is nice uh €0 a day which is about
$13 55 so yeah you could be an alcoholic
because of vodka or Jin but you're just
getting beer according to this um all
right I know we're going to have a lot
of funny stuff on this but is there are
they on to something here that they're
taking these people and making them
productive even though they're using
their addiction which obviously is kind
of sfe yeah but you know reading the
story a lot of times though people that
are addicted are are going to be
addicted no matter what you do so it
kind of gives them something one guy
said sure I know I I'm an alcoholic but
at least I I have I have a job now so it
gives me some pride um you know I
commend them for trying to do something
yeah you know they tried to do other
programs where they up security at the
parks to clear out the drunks just you
know laying on the the the park benches
and laying on the grass drinking and
being drunk all day well at least now
maybe they've gotten them down to where
we'll give them a couple beers and they
walk around and actually do something
instead of laying around all day being a
nuisance to the rest of society um you
know I don't know if it's the greatest
thing but I I commend them for doing
something I I don't I don't find it that
bad you know I'm not offended by it too
bad I mean maybe there there's better
ways but you know where is somebody else
making the better way or coming up with
a better idea we haven't come up with a
better idea so but is there no way to
incentivize good behavior you know what
I mean we're just reinforcing what
they're do that is what they're doing
actually I mean they're taking folks who
have an addiction and they're saying
okay uh these other issues are not
working kicking you out of the park
means you just mooved to a different
place but actually paying you to clean
up your Park and to have a a job that
you can give back to your community
seems to be working I mean the proof is
in the pudding and even if they did pay
them money or Euros it's going to go
they're going to go take the money and
go right to the liquor store and buy the
beer themselves anyway so they're just
paying them they're just taking out the
money middle part and paying them and if
you don't smoke they're going to use
that tobacco as bartering I'm sure
they're going to barter with it but one
guy did say so there is a little bit of
good that comes from the story one guy
said well I usually drink hard liquor
but you know now I just drink beer right
and so so that's a little bit better
right and also when I looked at when you
when you read further uh about more
about this particular program that they
have going you know one of the guys said
something that I thought was really
heartbreaking he's like you know I
guarantee you you look around at any of
the guys sitting around this table and
we all have our own little backpack of
misery that we carry around every day
this gives us a chance this gives gives
us hope it gives us a path out of this
right but aren't we also then or aren't
they also then filling that backpack
because we're in they're still enabling
the action that they're trying to you're
now thinking of a perfect Society then
we'd have no alcoholics no drunks no
heroin addicts No Coke users no
marijuana addicts I mean that really is
trying to make something very clean that
is never going to be you know unless we
really can completely cure alcoholism or
mental health issues or or drug
addiction but that's not going to go
away anytime soon I don't I think you're
trying to make a nice little bow that is
not reality you know what I mean and it
also takes care of other ills for
example when you have heroin addicts who
were given free methadone just to
basically you know stay off the streets
and not engage in criminal activity you
know that is an external benefit to this
particular policy that does come from
enabling these people so you know there
are I think trade-offs that come with
this if it's a policy that works and
actually helps these people you know
maybe move out of where they were into a
place where they're actually
participating and back deal but it's
better than doing nothing um do you
think this could ever work something
like this could ever work in the United
States because think about it right now
state byst state Le uh weed is is
getting legalized and I think in a
couple years it'll be probably legalized
Countrywide and it'll be fine and
everyone will go oh that wasn't such a
big deal sort of like a marriage
Amsterdam obviously has had uh marijuana
legal for many many years although it's
actually a little harder now to get than
it used to be um but is this just the
next natural step of trying to deal with
these vices so to speak in sort of more
mat ways if you're dealing with
something in a more practical pragmatic
way that actually accomplishes something
no I don't think we'll ever have that
here sorry I don't you know because I
don't think we're going to do that have
too many laws well how how bad of an
alcoholic are you do you make too much
money for us to give you free beer well
you could be doing this job inste there
would be too many problems and issues to
just say okay you're an alcoholic well
go clean the streets we'll give you pay
that you would have to fill out too much
paperwork and it would be too difficult
well I think we have too many moralistic
authoritarians who want to punish people
and they're not actually interested in
doing what's better they're not
interested in helping they're not
interested in making it better they just
want to punish them for not acting and
behaving in the way that these people
think they should behave and act in and
that that infuses all of our politics
bring us home well it's interesting I
was talking to Dr Drew the other day and
he said Penitentiary it used to be
penitence where we would take them into
our system if they broke the law and you
would reform them and rehabilitate and
put and bring them back out and to be
productive members of society and now we
just throw them in prison and throw away
the key that's Mak and we have private
prisons and all kinds of other stuff for
profit is completely Bonkers but that's
a whole other topic that we will also
try to get to next week okay final clip
here we go uh sex is exercise in case
you didn't know it uh a new study out of
the University of Quebec at Montreal uh
took a look at sex as a form of exercise
and they compared sex to jogging walking
uphill and playing tennis uh they looked
at 21 young straight Coupes so I'm not
sure what this means for gay sex um they
had them jog on treadmills for 20
minutes while researchers monitored
their energy expenditure in order to
provide a comparison for the physical
demands of sex and then if you're
wondering how they gauged how much uh
how many calories they burned during sex
the scientists gave volunteers an
unobtrusive armband uh to monitor the
exertion uh and the calories that were
burned during sex according to the study
sex is the equivalent of playing doubles
tennis or walking uphill okay pretty
good uh sex burned four calories per
minute for men and 3 minute for women uh
during sessions that rained from 10 to
57 minutes including foreplay uh the
average was 25 minutes men burned about
nine calories per minute jogging and
women about seven uh so obviously the
first question here is how important is
sex to your uh physical fitness do you
make it part of your workout routine no
I do not consider like oh I had sex with
my husband last night that's like going
to the gym I'm going to skip it tonight
uh first of all who who paid for this
report who paid for the research the
fine people that fund the
university people realizing wow
McDonald's is bad for you really sex
you're of course you're going to burn
some calories you're sweating your heart
beats up do we really need to know that
it's four
calories obiously wanted to actually
quantify and put some numbers to I mean
we've known this before but this is a
new and ingenious way I need know that
having sex is like playing doubles
tennis do I need to know that no I
probably ha these the people that came
up with this study well I just think
it's a study that you know can can you
put this money towards finding a cure
for cancer oh come on you know what I
mean well see now I didn't look at who
actually funded the study but I wouldn't
be surprised if folks like say Viagra
used these results to say see you know
this is like your gym membership yeah is
is this one of these things though we're
so afraid to talk about sex but if we
weren't afraid to talk about it people
would be having more sex and maybe uh
being healthier because of these
benefits in case you don't have access
to a tennis
court I just don't really see people
using that's a great would be
wonderful now you're both married if
your husband came home and said you know
I I ate like crap today and I feel I
just feel I don't feel great and I don't
I don't want to go to the gym it's cold
out and blah blah blah you know can we
do it for a couple hours would you see
that as a couple hours God all right how
long what are we talking 15 will you
give him 15 minutes well certainly you
probably wouldn't be laying down doing
it you know the oldfashioned way because
if you need to burn some calories you're
not going to the gym you better you
better get up and start moving around
well you could let him position that's
probably why men bore you know a burn a
few more calories than women because
guys are doing most of the work but
uh you're crazy first of all um but you
know come on people you should be having
sex for enjoyment there's so many other
things and just burning calories it
makes you feel better it clears your
mind you know they say orgasms promote
good health and and and feeling better
to if this helps folks that were maybe
on on the edge there and were not sure
they wanted to participate in this if
that helps them then buy goly honey more
power to or Al-Qaeda were having more
sex they would probably would want to
kill people less because they'd be
happier they're satisfied and calm they
have a you know they can be um well you
know Bill Maher has said many times that
in these countries that repress all this
sex stuff all you're doing you're
creating fertile ground for terrorism
because you're you're denying I've been
in these countries I've been to
Afghanistan and Pakistan and a lot of
most of the Middle East and you see it
you're you're walking down and I'm
covered modestly and they're still you
you see it in their eyes they almost
don't know they're looking at you you
know remember a cartoon and you you look
at an animal but you just see the the
the you know the the chicken and the
meat with the bones that's what I feel
like they're looking at but you feel The
Angst and the anger almost you know and
I'm just thinking God if you got laid
you would just feel so much better I
mean you're thinking that I mean it
honestly it's why so why with all the
information we have and everyone has you
know Twitter and all that even just uh
last night the Supreme Court in India
outlawed gay sex um so why do things
still keep moving backwards India is a
pretty uh Western Country uh even though
it's in that part of the world so why do
things still move backwards religion I
mean basically there's H you know that's
that's the foundation of of all
repression and suppression pretty much I
mean if you look at the books on a lot
of states in a lot of states in America
we in America there's still crazy you
know sodomy outlawed and most southern
states still and I mean even
consensual sex with chickens is Outlaw I
you know there's there's still weird
things on the books that people don't
necessarily follow it's like arbitrary
laws Mor moralistic authoritarian
tendency in our society I think is is
partly what is behind I always say if
it's behind my four walls in my house
and I'm not hurting anybody else just
leave me alone you can't regulate me
inside my home you can't regulate me
inside my home a good finish so get out
there and have some consensual sodomy
you sodomites you crazy sodomites Leanne
tweet and Desi doanne their Twitter are
right down below the Subscribe button is
right down below I'm sure there's some
other stuff right down below and we will
do it again next week okay
[Music]
thanks